when we shoot for something we shoot for
resilience
that's not it if you aim for resilience
you're not going to do very well
so
you know I decided to classify and this
book is about classification of things
into the three category
uh fragile robust anti-fragile
[Music]
I was an option Trader before I met
Danny we met in 2002 2003
and of course it changed a lot of things
for me I decided then to become a
scholar all right right after meeting
him immediately I said okay I'm going to
be a full-time scholar it took me a
couple of years you know to become a
scholar and of course I went and I had a
book that I had to revise
anyway before that I was an option
Trader and often trade is on very
sophisticated people
they know two things volatility and
alcohol all right so and they classify
things into things that like volatility
and think that hate volatility they're
packages that like volatility packages
that hate variability volatility
they call it long Gamma or short gamma
you know that was my specialty when I
entered the scholarly world I realized
that there was no name
for things that benefit from volatility
robust isn't it
you see things that are robust things
that are adaptable things that are agile
resilient destructively resilient
creatively resilient all these things
they're not the opposite of fragile and
they're not the equivalent of things
that gain from volatility so I decided
figured out that what a short volatility
is fragile this
doesn't like volatility because if
there's an earthquake in New York you
never know with uh you know Paul you
know maybe earthquakes here but
if there's an earthquake this is not
going to gain from the earthquake
you see so it does not like disorder it
does not like volatility it doesn't like
these things so I just you know figure
out that the fragile
is a category of object and the opposite
of fragile was not robust
the opposite of fragile had to be a
different category if I'm sending a
package to Siberia
fragile you know you translate into
Siberian or whatever Russian they use
Handle With Care the opposite wouldn't
be you know a robust package we write
nothing on it the opposite would be
something or which you would write
please mishandle
so there's no name for for that category
so I called it anti-fragile
what benefits from volatility has this
uh you know and I realized that somehow
the the you know people were into
intuitively wouldn't get it when we
shoot for something we shoot for
resilience
that's not it if you aim for resilience
you're not going to do very well
so you know I decided to classify and
this book is about classification of
things into the three category
uh fragile robust anti-fragile
so Danny there you go
well I mean you
you're almost forcing me to Define what
anti-fragile is because you haven't done
it but okay okay from variability
disorder uh stress uh what else
stressors uh harm uh things that that
benefit from from you know in an only
chapter of the book you have a very long
table yeah with three columns yes
fragile robust and anti-fragile and you
can pick any of the rows in that in that
table and elaborate on it for example
tourists and flannel
one of your favorite words uh
why why are tourists there is something
quite deep in in that
okay uh I was an option Trader option
you like optionality you see you like
uncertainty you benefit from uncertainty
you you like some disorder when you're a
tourist
you're on the track if the bus is late
you're in trouble
if you're an adventurer you you benefit
you you're opportunistically they can
imagine uncertainty so therefore you're
in that category of anti-fragile if
you're robust you don't care
so the idea of entrepreneurs are in a
category of anti-fragile
and the people who have you know very
rationalistic think put on track you're
following a you know
a certain code
you are fragile because if something
breaks you're in trouble you can't
nothing good you know
Can Can Happen things can go wrong but
they can get better so the fragile has
more downside than upside
uncertainty harms them take a plane ride
if you inject uncertainty into a plane
ride
I just came from Europe it was eight
hours
ended up to be 16. so that was eight
hours late did anyone have you ever
landed in JFK coming from Europe eight
hours early
no that's so category you inject
uncertainty the the the travel time
extends the opposite would be a system
in which you inject uncertainty you have
benefits and that's the anti-fragile
entrepreneurship
if you're an adventurer
you like uncertainty
and people you know couldn't get it I
have a way to explain it someone tells
me what's the difference was resilient
it says there's a big difference
if I buy insurance on my house and 10
times the amount needed
you know I want an accident to happen
you see it's not as I wanna every day a
morning I'd wake up I say there's no cow
no earthquake nothing in fact 10 times I
get paid 10 times the damages
so that's like inverse insurance
so insurance companies of course are
short volatility are harmed by disorders
they are fragile
and someone who has ten times insurance
would you know benefit from uncertainty
the mistake we made
yes ever since the enlightenment but
it's very exacerbated now because we're
more capable of controlling our
environment
we want to eliminate volatility from
life
we make the categorical mistake I call
it mistaken the cat for washing machine
I don't know if you own a cat or washing
machine they're very different
the washing machine will never self-heal
an organism needs some amount of
variability and disorder otherwise it
dies it actually an organism
communicates with the environment
via stressors
you see you you have stressors you you
put you know you lift weight your bones
are going to get thicker if you don't do
that if you go on a space shuttle you're
going to lose bone density so you need
stressors so people made a mistake of
thinking that the the the economy is
more like a some machine
that needs constant maintenance will
never get better and like this you put
it on a table okay you know it will be
harmed by any disorder and human body
that needs some amount of variability
that huge mistake led us to micromanage
the economy into chaos take forest fires
if you extinguish every forest fire
single forest fire a lot of flammable
material would accumulate
and the big one would be a lot worse so
what Mr Greenspan did actually he's
writing a book he probably may come here
for an interview
the Greenspan did is he micromanaged the
economy and had you given him the
seasons or the nature he was a fixed
nature at 68.7 degrees year-round no
more seasons so of course things got
weaker and you had the pseudostability
you then himself that you know you met
you've mentioned in your writings that
human beings are a chicken okay they
usually they claim to have a lot of
Courage so they take risks they don't
know they like to take risks they don't
understand
because when you because when you're
shown variability and riska gets scared
so we try to manage things over manage
things our health the economy a lot of
things into complete chaos and fragilize
it that's a mistake the first mistake is
mistaking something organic for an
engineered product
so that's the first mistake and of
course that has a psychological there's
a psychology behind it no
we can argue an an end of federal
this is robust because the implications
of your argument
are I think
okay are costly I mean there is a cost
they're necessary they're beyond
necessary if I if if I put someone a
child completely deprive the stressors
in a sterilized room for five years and
then bring him here to visit the New
York subway
you know next door you know how long how
many minutes will he last okay so
visibly if you're not exposed to
Threshers
you're going to be weakened okay we're
getting we have a society that is
obsessed by eliminating small stressors
small risk at the expense of large risks
and this manifests itself a lot of
things the fact that we didn't have a
name for anti-fragile means half of life
doesn't have a name it didn't matter in
the old days because we have stressors
all the time
now we control our environment and we
control the wrong thing about the
environment we try to make the right
comfortable but don't eliminate the
large risk in fact it's the opposite in
any field we've been harmed but I call
it denial of anti-fragility
denial of anti-fragility Greenspan
wanted to smooth out the economy create
a no more woman bust
no it's natural to have woman busts some
in some amount he created a big bust
okay
in in in in uh and we're discovering
there's something called Jensen's
inequality
means some properties of non-linear
response that makes you benefit from
variability
your food intake if you eat food if you
eat on you know if your calories you
always have the same amount of calories
all the time you're gonna be injured
uh you know if you stay in on a chair
all no stressor all right you're not
your back is gonna become weaker stuff
like that but you can generalize so what
I've done here is try to identify the
blind spot we have today
that matter today did not matter in the
past because in the past we had the
environment was providing us with
stressors take for example temperature
it's not healthy to stay at 68.7 degree
24 hours
it's not healthy you need variability
we're made for very we're made for an
environment you know where you have big
thermal fluctuation so you injure
yourself and effectively now have
catalog of things
harm you're getting from not getting
variability
likewise in the economy if you don't
have think of the restaurant business if
you don't have
bankruptcies in a restaurant business
what would happen tonight we're going
out to dinner all right the quality of
the meal
is a direct result of the fragility of
individual restaurants
system to be robust and anti-fragile
needs to recycle improve the fragility
of the components okay otherwise you
know look at Russia the restaurant
didn't go bust I don't know if you ate
food in the 70s in Russia but some
people are still trying to recover from
The Experience right so
but I have one more thing to say
A system that does not
convert stressors problems variability
into fuel is doomed
let me give you a system that's
perfectly
adapted to converting stressors into
Improvement
the Air transport in the last seven
years we had one plane crash commercial
plate crash not I mean I'm not talking
about individuals flying on weekends you
know half drunk plane crash for you know
major airlines
why every plane crash that has happened
had
made the next plane Ride Safer lowered
the probability of next plane crash
every plane crash that's a system that
is
overall anti-fragile where you benefit
you don't never let a mistake
go to waste now compare that to the
banking system
a bank crash would make the probability
of a next Bank crash
much more likely all right much higher
that's not a very good system
just like in the economic system booms
and bursts are natural to humans and
thus the way we should work deep work
deep rest get the feedback loop repeat
just like sahil Bloom tweeted work like
a lion most people are not wired to work
nine to five modern world culture is
remnant of the Industrial Age which is
long periods of steady monotonous work
if your goal is to do Inspire creative
work you have to work like a lion Sprint
when Inspire rest repeat I leave you
with some tables from the book
anti-fragel by Nasim taleb which was
discussed during this video for each row
we can see a different kind of event
activity or system
and then in the columns we can see how
it fits into the fragile category robust
category and anti-fragile category
would you like to get access to the
finest nuggets from the best non-fiction
books out there if you do you should
check out short form for disclosure
short form is not sponsoring this video
but there is an affiliate Link in the
video description why am I promoting
short form well my purpose through this
channel is to collect valuable insights
from videos of people that I deeply
admire now imagine if you can easily get
the most valuable insights from the best
non-fiction books this is what you can
find on short form a curated selection
of the best books and for each book you
can find a carefully crafted summary in
which all the book's relevant ideas are
analyzed this is why I absolutely love
to read on short film and would
recommend it to anyone as Charlie Monger
argues to have a good unsuccessful life
you have to create a mental model from
all the big ideas from all the big
disciplines and short form can be
extremely helpful for this matter as it
literally extracts all the big ideas
from the best non-fiction books helping
you to create this mental a model in a
faster and more efficient way and with
these valuable ideas becoming second
nature to us over time I think we will
be able to build our best lives by
standing on the shoulders of giants as
Seer Isaac Newton would put it now the
way I personally read on short form is
to pick from my personal Library any
book that sparks my interest at that
moment and start reading it typically I
will read sometimes in the morning after
waking up sometimes at night before
going to sleep and many times I will do
a short read on the mobile phone app
when for instance I'm in a restaurant
alone waiting for the food or commuting
somewhere I created my personal Library
by quickly scan through all their books
on short form and for any book to make
it on my library it has not only to
interest me but it also must fulfill at
least one of two conditions one is that
I already know the author of the book
from an interview in some podcast or any
other source that I personally trust and
the other is that the book itself has
been publicly recommended by people who
I deeply admire if you are interested in
short form you can visit my special link
sure dot com slash speaking nuggets or
use the link in the description below to
receive unlimited access for 5 days and
a 20 discount on the annual subscription
if you do choose to keep going after the
end of your trial thanks for watching if
you enjoyed the greeting content in this
video you will love our newsletter where
you can get in your email all the
greeting content plus the latest things
that I've been pondering to subscribe
always for free find the link below in
the description
thank you